So you've seen that the constant turn that we would get if we multiplied this
entire right hand side of the equation out, is the product of the constant
terms negative six, two and negative four from each of the original factors
that we had. So that means that this number 48 here is pretty intimately
related to the factors of this polynomial. That means that we should be able to
use some information involving 48 to get to the roots of this polynomial.
There's gotta be a pretty close connection there. So let's say we have some
fourth degree polynomials to add. Maybe it's this one, f of x equals x to the
4th minus 23x squared plus 18x plus 40. And maybe I've also come up with some
guesses for how to factor this polynomial. Let me write them down for you.
Which of these three choices down here do you think is the correct
factorization of this function? Remember to think about what we need in terms
of this constant up here.